[拍手]
じゃあ
今日はですねあのロボットの創造の過程と酒杯と
という話をしたいと思います
これはの昔のと古代の体育館で
カーてを練習している時の様子ですけども
こういう武道をやるときにですね
まず方を留分に学ぶと
それからそれを実際の組み手とか
悲哀を使ってだんだん変形させていって最終的には自分なりにまた新しい方を学習する
というようなことが言われていますねまあ僕自身も起こらのニュージーランドができた
学生で巻かれをまだ
長尾だから
ああああああ
8幕見て教えててあの上段回し蹴りがが綺麗に決まっているところの扶養するなんです
けどね
はいやまずその日についてお話します
ジョイペット動画をお願いします
これはですねええ暇蛇をを使った実験をしている時の様子です
私はあの男ないきて
まああの大試合機械工学学んだんですけども
何か新しいことをやりたいと思ってですね柔らかい機会を作ろうと思いました
精密さあとか早さとかそういうのを追求するんじゃない柔らかい機会をつくろうと思っ
たときにそれの一番典型的な例はまあ蛇だろうということでヘビの動きをまず
学ぼうと考えたわけですこういうや人工芝生を聞いた
舞台装置を作って実験をしました
でまぁ調べていくとですねその
蛇がなぜ足がなくて前に進めるかという議論がほとんどなかったんですね動物ラフィア
ちょっとやんちゃな研究しかなくて
まあ工学的にちゃんキャットようなものがなかったんでそれの理論をまず作りまして
ここにあるように
これはの筋電計
筋肉は力を出すと日そんな電流が流れるんですけども
その金でんりを測るセンサーとか体が地面を横に押す力を測る攻戦力系というのおり
自分で作って走らせましたそうするとこういう測定点はだんだんなんかを移動している
わけですよね
ねこうやって体に沿ったアーキン
陰力とか力の様子を測定してどんな
力を出すと
前に行けるかとない研究をしたわけですまああのこの辺非常に面白い話になるんです
けれども
えっとそのうちのですねねぇ
ヘビの体がどんな形をしているかという話をしたいと思います
でまぁこの曲線ですねこの曲線一体どんな曲線なのかというわけです
で
この話をする
前座としてですねこれずっとアドなんですけどもスコットランドの学生が来てたんで
ある年にその人力蛇車を作ろうと提案しました
これはですね蛇の筋肉になったつもりで前の車輪をご足でこう
曲げてやるとちょうど波が前からヒロに伝わるような形になると
前進できるとあのやみくもに行っても全然前がなんですけど馬明と思えるんですね
で
その皆さんがその子の学生になってどういうふうに前の
台車をしたらいいのかというものを考えてもらうというわけです
まああのこれあの非常に協調性がいてですねえっと
あのムカデ競争ってありますけども
ありゃの完全に同期しなきゃいけないんですこれはさらに難しくて位相をずらしてやん
なきゃいけないですね
ですからあのもうちょっと高級な運動会のあのいう部になるんじゃないなというような
話もしてたんですけどね
すっ
それで例えばこういう3角波を作っ作るような指に足を動かそうとしたらどうするかと
いうとこのピンク天の気にですね
p のところで突然パス異様に pot バスト
れパックバスご案内と三角を作れない
そんな著
アリアですねじゃあ円弧はどうかっていうと円弧はえーっ opo わぁある角度にて
横転でかくってますとまたそのまんま同じ曲率で言ってか食ってますと
というわけですね
これはこれもなかなかちょっと不自然ですよね
ぎゃっ宣言ハードか正弦波はあのまああの何回微分してもサインコサインサイン
コサインとずーっと連続関数だから持っても連続性の高い曲線などです
ところがすごいちょっとを思い返してみるとで
すね y子さん x というのを微分するとラウンドは選んで食ってやるのはこれは
xe 9に対してですね
x 軸に対しての変化率
しかしその曲線に沿って動かしたときの曲線の変化率というものを計算してみるとじつ
はあの
こういうふうに変な所なんですね
ですからあのわざわざこんな辺で貼っこうしてもう曲げるって正弦波を作るなんてこと
は考えられないから
これどうも変だというわけです
じゃあその
これをですね一定速度で曲げてあるのかと
って速度で曲げるとどうなるかというとこれが
s に沿った変化率は直線1時間数になる訳ですけどそれは
曲線に沿って曲率が1時間数で変化するものは
クロソイド曲線と言われていますここ言い方ですねスパイラル状になる理由
でですからこのクロソイドスパイラルをつないでの形になるとこれはなかなかあのまあ
近いかもしれない格好良いですね
で a
8ついでに言うとですねあの皆さんあまり知らないかもしれないですけれども
高速道路のこの曲線ですねこの曲線はクロソイド曲線になっています
なぜかというと
曲線から円弧で直線にカーブを作るとハンドローですね直線からインクに入ったら突然
クっと曲げてそのまま止めて直線に戻るギャップって戻すとっていうことなんですね
それは何か良いをするシーンですこれクロソイドですと曲線からカーブに入ると言って
速度で回して
低速でで戻して直線に戻るということで滑らかにな運転ができるというわけです
ですからまああのこれもなかなかいいんですけども
でもやっぱりこう直線と曲のつなぎが折れて折れ線ですからまた微分するとどんどん不
連続になっていますよね
ですからあんまり言わないと
じゃあ一番いいのはないかというと曲線に沿って曲線に沿って曲率が
正弦波的に代わるものが一番いいじゃんとか考えられるわけですね
でじゃあそういう曲線がどうかというとまあ計算してみるとこんな形になります
で
まあこれは当たり前の考え方をこのってその頃数学辞典とかですねいろんな文献調べた
けれども曲線に沿って曲率が制限発言にカール曲線っていうのは
全く出てないんですね
っていうことでまああの藁焼き研究者から誰も見つけてない曲線見つけたと思ってそれ
をサーフィンの井戸さあテントの
ができた曲線キュートサーフィンの井戸カーブというと名付けました
で実際それが蛇と一致するかどうかという実験もしまして蛇をですね
能望リーのスウェット拡大のスロープに走らせると
下りは直線的に入厩しな登りだと大きく蛇行するんですけども
それを全部まとめて色々なカーブでやっていくと
8まあこれがはの平均値とへ
平太共有編そうですけれども
さーての井戸カーブが一番近くてクロソイドがこれでこれは正弦波クラ円弧というふう
にやはりサープヌードカーブが実際とよく敵をするということが分かりました
でまぁあの実際のヘビの形がわかったわけですけれどもこれはすごく当たり前の曲線だ
と思うんですけどじゃあ最初は全然思いつかなかったんですね
でそれを用いたのがですね実はその
そう号による改正起案なり雪梅スペインスイスというプロセスだったということもあの
説明したいと思います
これは僕はそのヘビの
実験をやった次の年190972年に
えっと動いた蛇型ロボどうです間に目20節あってですね
8各関節はサーブ系で際に動くわけですね
これをどうやってうわそうというのを待つ食ってる間に色々考えているのですね
そうすると1番センターにある左右に曲がる波形を入れてそれ後ろに一定速度で送って
いくというあるセグ家作ったわけですけどその波形をどうしようかと考えていくとまぁ
あの
3回れればクロソイ丼
あるしとかって考えてまぁ当然正弦波だよねーと考えてあの波形が出てきた
で実際のヘビに実験してもヘビのえっと波形を見るとやっぱり同じだったということが
わかったわけですよ
つまりですねその正体のように非常に複雑なシステムを理解しようという時にそのそれ
を分析してどんどんや
あの解析するというまでカルトがやってきたような解析方法がまああの普通の王道な
わけですけども
そうじゃなくて自分がもう神様になったつもりで
ぷっちゃう作ってみるとじつは中身が英語があるというのが
analysis by シンセスなんですね
でまぁそれをこれで体験したということです
でもう一つこの話はあの後日談があってですね
これをやった後もしばらく忘れてたんですけども
96年
いいですねその uc バークレー武先生からの手紙をいただきました
でその先生はですね僕はのバールキャリイスパロボットっていう本あのオク騒動にバー
シプレ作り出したんですけどもその本を読んで行に面白かったかでその僕がその提案し
ているさあぺの井戸カーブというのは
あ
率は彼はを川の蛇行を表現する曲線と全く同じ
数式であるということを言ったんですね彼はそれを3位じぇねれーキールカーブだと
いうことです
なぜかというとその曲線
蛇行する川が蛇行する時のまま
ある要因になる因子が川に沿って正弦波的に変化するから
a
ソロサイン人抜いているカーブあれはサーフィンロード買うになるということで1
僕は昔からそのから見ると本当にこうヘビーと同じだなあと思ってたんですけども実は
数学的にも全く問題だということが後になって分かったということもあります
まああのう
さあペろいどカーブという生をつけるときにその
そのシビルエンジニアリングの方までちゃんと調べれば見つかったのかもしれないん
ですけどまたまたま
見つからなくてまあ今のこのサーフィンの井戸カーブはヘビ型ロボットを作る一つ世界
牛の作る人はこれをみんな使っています
さてそれではこの度実際の動きを見せしましょう
ここにヘビ型ロボットを持ってきました
ところですねええっ
車輪が付いてますけどこの車輪はみんなパッシブです
ローラーですね動かしてください
で8前から後ろにコナミをを伝えると蛇行運動するわけですね
日にちょっと狭いから運転をなかなか注意しないといけないですけども
でへと斜めにもこれあの
左右に回ろうと同時に前後にも曲がる関節があるので斜めにしても
左右と上下の半分ずつ曲げてあれば45度で動くこともできます
でこれどのような姿勢をとっても車輪が常に地面を接するようになっているんですね
それからまあなんか先端にカメラがあってその鎌首をもたげて
えっと点検をするなんていうことも出来ると言うようですね
だ祖母のやんライブんがそういうしてるんですけどね
はい
はいええっこんなものがまあ蛇ロボットですねうん
でその後水陸両用のヘビ型あーロボットも作りました
やって上場僕は日ください
これは円筒形の胴体の間に同じく左右と上下に回るアクチュエーターがモーターが入っ
てましてそれを全体をベローズでジャバラでカバーしています
ですから中に空気が入っているので
全体の比重は1できるようにしています
ですから非常にあの軽く浮いているような感じですからあの地上よりはるかに滑らかに
水中を泳ぎ回ることができるわけですね
えっと
まああのこれはの水中でいるの点検ができて狭いところから入っていけるんだまあ色が
その後いろんな応用がそのされています
じゃあ次に母を説明しましょう今まではあの蛇と同じものを全く似たものを作ろうとし
てますけども
必ずしもそれにこだわる必要はないんですねでその生物を真似するということではなく
てですね
まあそれも使うけど使えるものは全部使っていくというものが実用的な
ロボットを作るためには重要になります
例えばこれはですねあ後で oppo 掴んでやるとループ状になると
やっぱり縁はこんなことじゃないんですよね
でループ状になるとああの動く車輪ができるというわけですね
ヘビはこう地面にコスあの滑りますから
摩擦ケースまだつが抵抗があってやっぱりそんな効率は良くない
蛇あんまり協議が走れないですね結構疲れちゃうからあのできないんですけども
こういうその滑りのない動きができたらまあもっと多いを低い上げ狭いところはズって
言って
ループ状に移動するということも出来ると言うようですね
からこれはですねえっとぉ
ヘビをあのこれはパッシブな車輪ですけれどもこの車輪をアクティブにしてやるかを
もっと運動性能があります
直線上るももちろんいけるあのこれは断交しないといけないんですけど直線業務を
いけるというような
ヘビ型ロボットになります
でこれはですねええ去年 nhk のダーウィンが来たで放映したんで見たこと方も
あるかもしれないですけれども
タスマニア島にあるえっと本バット州の巣穴を覗こうという
プロジェクトに使われましたこれがウォンバットの巣穴でこれがヘビ型ロボット
使用前費用子ですね泥だらけになっているという状況ですね
でバーン山田君で枚ね死刑のディレクターという
ですね
今日は中の様子はどうなっているかと言うとこれは前の
これ先端のカメラでこちら広野カメラの様子ですけども
父ならずっとそうなをつくっていろいろ分岐していように複雑が
数を作ってるんですけれどもそんながのぞいていったわけですそれでウォンバットは
言うたはずのところへ行くとですね
どうも見えないと
りよーく見てみるとどうもその多くの方ですね
ok つを向けて隠れてたというですね
ウォンバットのお客が非常に強くてですね
あのなんかこういうディフェンスの態勢を取るぺいつも多穴を見せてあの
頭隠して尻隠さずの態勢を取るということで顔は見えなかったですけどもう穴はメイド
という
一見になりましたまた蛇がたのですね
川瀬細いところに入るの敵しますから
レスキュー用にも使うことができます
これはの警視庁
がやったデモの様子ですけれども化学プラントで
事故があったと言うような想定で人間が入っていけないような時ですね入っていこうと
いうわけです
でこれはからにモディファイしてですねその3つのクローラーと
魚員とアクティブな教員と使うとずっとシンプルな構造になっているわけですけれども
やっぱりそのヘビと同じような移動性は実現できる
狭い所にも入っていくことができるという運動性を持っています
サーモビジョンと普通のカメラをつけていてマージンたいあの当たった髪があれば
ちゃんと見つけられるというなヘビ型ロボットになっています
さらに
りですね
今まではそのヘビに近いがたちをちょっとあの新しい機能をつけるということで行って
きたんですけれども
別にそのヘビにこだわらない立場でも有効になります
蛇の研究の後には歩行ロボットの研究をしたんですけども
荒地ではまあそのあるくって言います効果的です
ダンサーがあったりとか飛び石みたいなとこ動くっていうのは国交がいいんですけども
大和でしたらやっぱり車輪が一番ですね大だーにポンポン走ってすごいあの言葉って
いうのは研究があるけど
をあんな何気なくてですね車輪ギターあるかに便利素敵なんですね
でもその
しゃるーんあのモーター付きでブレーキがついたりとかっていう想いシャーリングを足
の先にくっつけるといけない
8を重すぎるとようですねそこでこの2つをうまく
ハイブリッド化する構成を考えて結局ちぎのようなアンモデルを作りました
これは
荒地ではあるいきます
とちょっと書いたん8というのはイヤー駆動型の歩行器科医ですけども
で平らなぁ
そのハイウェイとかに来たらばですねその足のらを90度傾ける
ですねでこれはあの根元にある小さいモーターで売約どうでしているんでほとんど足の
重量は増えないんですけども
そうしますと足先がローラースケートのローラーになるわけですね
でや
ドン追加した父兄たを分なくてもですね
足を怖回せばちゃんと推進できるようですね
で
とまぁあのくだりはちょっと暴言みたいにしてると思う
聖堂がかけられる
廊下であるとまあまあ時速10キロ以上のスピードは出せると
ですね今度はほとんど足をあの進行方向を向けています
だぶれーじやる客を暴言をやると
これちょっと斜めに移動する
ですねこちら思います
から斜面を登るときは大きな軌道であると水流かちゃんと出ると
ですねこうやってそのまあ自由自在に平地であれば有事ない動き回ると
で使ってえらくケーターは歩行のための合計1020度しか使ってないということで
歩行ロボットの機能性がずっと上がるということになります
あの[ __ ]運動する時はまぁちょっと起動はまた変わるんですけれども
滑ったらまあ障害物走もできますよということ
it
要するにですね
あの
歩行っていうのはもう全然別の者なんですけどもそれのハイブリッドを考えたりする
ときにその蛇ロボットで学んだ
つまりその蛇ロボットの本質は摩擦係数の違う
大変みたいなを使って一方向には滑りやすい軽量歩行には滑りにくいとそれをうまく
買ってやると前進できると
いうことなんですけれどもそれを使ったほか原理まあこれあの子に会いにつけた led
の軌跡で正經見るみたいな動きになるわけですけれどもそれを使っていたというわけ
ですね
ということでその主播いいですねその日というその
まず蛇ロボットの研究では生物からバブというその基本的なスタンスはあの非常に重要
でそれから非常に多くのことが学べます
しかしそれだけじゃなくて
そのそれをさらに公募にふぁいして新しいもっと新しいコンセプトを入れていくという
ことで機能性も上がっていくと最終的にはもうその形なんかどうでもいいとその本質
だけ使ってしまえばもっと
より良いものが出来るというのはいいですこういう考え方はそのロボット開発で上げ
なくてもより
広い分野で適用できると思うので
まあ皆さん覚えていていただければいいと思いますご静聴ありがとうございます
[拍手]